jean-vincent placé le président du
groupe écologiste au sénat est l'invité
de preuves par 3 public sénat afp
dailymotion bonsoir jean vincent placé
et merci d'être avec nous un pendant 45
minutes sans interruption
si celle des reportages le premier
portera sur les vos camarades militants
qui rêve d'une autre alliance vert rouge
dans la foulée de votre départ du
gouvernement et le second reportage sur
le sujet qui est faire en fait de vous
le grand allié de manuel valls la fin
annoncée des départements puisque vous
êtes son seul relais au sénat sur ce
sujet et également sur sa méthode avec
nous ce soir perrine tarneaud de public
sénat et jean luc prévost de l' agence
france-presse d'abord d'une première
question sur les risques de guerre
civile désormais au coeur même de
l'europe une fois de plus la dîmière
poutine agit à sa guise pour empêcher
l'ukraine de se tourner vers l'europe
comme est ce que vous voyez le président
et maîtres absolus russe
le problème du maître absolu russe
secure il est à la tête d'un état très
puissant très riche aujourd'hui et très
militarisée et donc le rapport de force
dans la zone est extrêmement sa faveur
moi j'ai évidemment suivi de très près
comme l'ensemble des passionnés de
l'europe la situation en ukraine mais je
me suis réjoui du retour de la
démocratie du fait qu' il ya un
mouvement populaire mais après il faut
être quand même extrêmement attentif à
ce qui se passe c'est à dire que la
crimée on voit que on a reculé assez
rapidement
ce scénario la réalité aussi c'est que
personne ne s'est intéressé à ce qu'est
par exemple tout simplement l'armée
ukrainienne qui est totalement
inexistante ce qui fait que assez
intelligemment dans son optique poutine
avance ses pions vers le nième prend fin
c'est ça la réalité aussi bien à kharkiv
que à donetsk suscitant des mouvements
et moi je suis extrêmement inquiet par
cette situation est une auto crew tout à
la fois non mais moi je pense que c'est
une erreur de la part des européens
d'essayer d'en faire un épouvantail idée
ce qu'il est on peut le qualifier de ce
qu'on veut ça n'a strictement pour le
coup pour le règlement du problème
l'ukrainien aucun intérêt simplement
parce que certes nous sommes assez actif
et je me réjouis d'action de lancer
certains avaient été mises affaires
étrangères de la zone en particulier les
allemands et les polonais mais la
réalité c'est que comme personne
évidemment selon une forme et
malheureusement daté mais bien connu
personne va mourir pour kiev eh bien il
faut trouver une solution négociée et
pour avoir une solution négociée ça sert
pas à grand chose de faire le matamore
en insultant si j'ose dire le futur
partenaire et qui n'est pas encore un
adversaire alors qu'en plus à aucun des
moyens militaires ce qui d'ailleurs
souligne un autre sujet au delà de
diplomatie et on l'avait déjà dit
notamment au moment de la syrie c'est à
dire la faiblesse de de la défense
européenne qui n'existe en temps moi je
ne suis pas militariste et vous le savez
écologistes mais mettent eux-mêmes il
faut que tout de même que oui mais
attention une baisse du budget notamment
sur la question de la dissuasion
nucléaire moi j'ai toujours été
favorable à une force d'intervention qui
soit efficace et la voyez-vous quand on
n'a plus beaucoup de soldats pour
pouvoir être actif donc on n'a pas
beaucoup d'arguments de rapports de
force et donc il faut arriver à une
solution négociée intelligente pour que
monsieur poutine se mettent autour de la
table aussi les sujets d'ailleurs
économique est particulièrement fort son
plan énergétique tout une question du
gaz est ce qu'il faudrait tout de suite
passé au niveau maximal des sanctions
économiques par exemple prévu contre
moscow rui vous je sais que c'est l'idée
ensuite le savent on en veut sanctionner
non pas tellement voulant y avait moi je
pense que avec madame merkel et monsieur
poutine il faut discuter et quelque part
on voit que c'est un sujet en temps réel
il n'intéresse pas du tout les
américains ils n'ont pas d'intérêt dans
la zone et ça les indiffère et donc nous
ils sont il faut qu'on soit plus
volontariste essayer de mettre peut-être
que de rentrer avait on vous écoute
volontariste en mairie il faut il faut
tenir compte du rapport en devient
souvent tout à la politique je n'ai pas
fait ce soir et géostratégiques ou
nationale eh bien il ya le rapport de
force vous dites personne ne va mourir
pour kiev et en même temps on a vu des
ukrainiens mourir pour l'europe oui mais
bien sûr cela il faut les conforter
seulement voilà quand on dit et c'est
logique c'est une message de départ nous
touche ne touchons pas intégrité
territoriale bien sûr après on voit
qu'elle est déjà atteinte avec la crimée
et que de toute façon c'est irrémédiable
donc à ton cela et essayons de faire en
sorte que lié à trois une zone de
discussion russie ukraine union
européenne est encore en vie je vais
vous dire à force de forcer sur le
partenariat et c'est pas tout à fait la
position de mes petits camarades à force
de passer de forcer sur le partenariat
uniquement avec l'union européenne eh
ben on va finir par la partition pour le
phocéen qui fleurit camarades parce
qu'ils ont compris mes amis verts aussi
bien qu'ils sont qui sont très oui oui
voilà à l'on dit que cuite ukraine
europe oui ils ont raison ça me voilà
attention car attention parce qu'à la
réalité au delà des slogans et du
volontarisme l'autre facette de l'europe
l'enjeu économique la france s'est fait
sèchement remettre sur les rails
apparemment sur les bons rails et même
la réduction à trois pour cent des
déficits en 2015 ça reste l'objectif
intangible a bien souligné bruxelles
est-ce que selon vous manuel valls est
pris à revers après avoir affirmé qu'il
rejetait l'austérité qu'ils voulaient
donner des explications à bruxelles
on a signé le traité on a signé le
traité - le début de devant les
critiques à la politique économique de
françois hollande cela remonte à ce
moment là on avait dit c'était
d'ailleurs daniel cohn bendit qui avait
trouvé la formule brillante comme
souvent le traité merkozy donc c'était
le traité fait par madame merkel
monsieur sarkozy qui consiste à
effectivement à mettre tout le monde
dans une vision de réduction des
déficits et de la dette c'est pas
honteux en soi d'ailleurs ça dépend
après quel niveau de fiscalité c'était
une défense alléguait toute une
génération l'écologisme nom ne vous dit
pas il faudra c'est gratis il faut faire
des déficits
on s'en fout faisant payer tout le monde
dépensant n'importe quoi ça n'a jamais
été le discours écologiste après c'est
savoir qui paye et au niveau des impôts
et qui voit les coupes budgétaires et
sur un poste donc c'est ça le débat
aujourd'hui on est arrivé à une forme
d'équivalence de ce qu'on faisait avant
sous la droite c'est à dire la rgpp la
révision générale des changements des
politiques publiques et
j'ai déjà même oublié l'acronyme nouveau
qui doit être la réorganisation
administrative ou je ne sais quoi et le
sujet c'est de dire mais on va faire -3
à -4% partout ça n'a strictement aucun
sens on avait dit dès priorité à
l'éducation à la jeunesse à la justice à
la sécurité bon ben si ça doit se
manifester quand même un peu
budgétairement vous donc à l'aller nous
les écologistes nous sommes attachés
rites et non je pense que en réalité et
le débat évidemment et sur les 3 % et je
pense quand même que c'est quand même
encore un mauvais message on avait dit
qu'on allait renégocier on ne négocie
pas on avait dit qu'on avait depuis
volontariste et desserrer l'étau
d'austérité les rieurs on va faire un
déplacement à berlin puis beaumont dit
bah en fait non on va faire ce que les
allemands et bruxelles veulent je suis
pas sûr ce soit un message qui renforce
le sentiment et la sympathie des
françaises et des français par rapport à
l'union européenne qui voit plus
maintenant comme un carcan une
contrainte comme une difficulté parce
que par rapport à une volonté ou un
enthousiasme aux quelque chose qui qui
provoque du bien et donc là on a une ré
difficulté mais moi je faisais et je le
répète régulièrement
y compris au plus haut niveau de l'état
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire je comprends
le message vis-à-vis des entreprises je
ne veux pas comme le président comme le
premier ministre que le message
vis-à-vis des entreprises ça soit les
entreprises et font n'importe quoi on va
leur mettre des impôts dessus ils ont
besoin de deux contraintes
supplémentaires c'est pas ça le débat
moi je suis prêt à aider des entreprises
mais à côté de ça il faut qu'il y ait
établi non parce que le problème c'est
la question du volet économie c'est on
ne peut pas expliquer aux françaises et
aux français y compris dans la tradition
politique colbertiste qui est la nôtre
on va aider les entreprises et on va
serrer le kiki de des services publics
c'est pas possible c'est un message qui
est totalement comment il faudra bien
qu'on arrive aux 3% et donc on en
arrivait aussi aux débats la réforme
fiscale alors j'ai truc tu es dans tout
il faut réussir explique qu'en tout à la
fois on veut aider les entreprises tout
à la fac on veut des services publics
fut alors j'ai une guerre cela il faut
des dépenses publiques j'ai une question
très large public c'est aussi la
consommation présente reprise et c'est
aussi l'investissement des
infrastructures président en question
sera historique sur une taxe à l'écotaxe
l'écotaxe savez que vous allez arriver
sur ségolène royal qui est le
portefeuille d'une écologie d'ailleurs
qui aurait pu vous rêvez vous revenir
enfin à vous les verts jean vincent
placé
à une vision toute personnelle
manifestement de certains sujets et sur
l'écotaxe et de la trouvent injuste pour
les camions français est ce votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'il faut la réserver aux
camions étrangers je vais vous dire je
suis pour qu'on fasse de la pédagogie
bien sûr sur la fiscalité et quand il
qu'on a à faire la fiscalité eh bien il
faut en faire voilà on s'y est pris
comme des manches des pieds chacun
de ces expressions mais ce qu'on aime
sincèrement on arrive on a redit qu'ils
avaient sur liliane 30 noms mais je
développe quand même parce qu'on n'avait
pas parlé degottex comme ça il ya 30
milliards d'impôts fait par la droite
nous on arrive en fait 30 milliards déjà
on prend leur ait pu peut-être essayer
d'anticiper la trajectoire sur les cinq
ans en faire un peu la première année
dire que c'est juste et que ce sera la
dernière fois pour le quinquennat sera
était déjà plus intelligent c'est la
difficulté vu aujourd'hui le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires et te fait la
perception par les françaises et les
français que c'est difficile la
pédagogie sur les impôts donc on a fait
un peu n'importe quoi on arrive dans une
séquence où je me souviens que les
économies lui-même avait dit à williams
a ras le bol fiscale
mais je vais quand même si parce que il
ya eu l'histoire ensuite des bonnets
rouges etc etc on vous dira pour vous
dire oui je comprend quelque part la
ministre de l'écologie par rapport aux
fêtes voyez c'était ça l'intérêt de
désistement d'être pédagogique
de je comprends que la ministre de
l'ecologie n'ai pas envie d'arriver avec
sa première action qui soit de la
fiscalité et de revenir sur la querelle
de l'écotaxe moi ça fait longtemps que
je dis à mes petits camarades toujours
les mêmes les verts je leur dis mais
attention la fiscalité écologique ça
paraît simple mais j'avais dit à nicolas
hulot qui comme le grand fondateur de la
taxe carbone taxe carbone voyez comment
il ya une acceptabilité comme ça que le
royal vous n'avez pas là l'école blangy
punitive mais ce qu'ils ne voient jamais
les cotations de nour étrange il faut et
je passe à ce stade là ce qui me paraît
important c'est qu'il faut dégager d'une
façon ou d'une autre les 800 millions
d'euros qui étaient destinés à voilà aux
investissements de l' agence française
de la france sont les dégagements sont
uniquement les camions des dons moi ce
que je veux rien mais est aux frontières
de la voilà mon problème à moi c'est de
trouver
celui de ségolène royal elles m'ont fait
une proposition en tant qu'écologistes
et en tant que président gros
parlementaire c'est d'essayer pour la
loi de finances parce que le
gouvernement propose nous sommes encore
un pays où le parlement vote les budgets
et la fiscalité et donc il faut qu'on
trouve en lien et ségolène royal avec
les premières pistes qu'elle a indiqué
par rapport à 2008 mais par exemple
j'avais dit essayons de regarder les
essieux c'est à dire que techniquement
plus les camions est gros et plus on le
taxe déjà il y avait même pas de
progressivité du décompte est passé on
écarte et camille à la fiction des
étrangers eux par exemple moi j'ai une
proposition c d'exonérer si j'ose dire
le cabotage routier c'est à dire que
quand on fait 2 100 km et 200 premiers
kilomètres ils sont exonérés pour voyez
comme sa balle envoyée pour la bretagne
c'est très adapté on n'est pas non plus
plus idiots ils ont beaucoup
d'exonération et on peut essayer
d'étendre la discussion donc moi je
souhaite qu'on remette et ça ce sera
effectivement le rôle et le fait très
bien moi je suis déjà dit mais je suis
très content que ségolène royal soit là
ministre des colonnes avance des propos
selon l'ancienne candidate avec son
présidentielles du parti socialiste et
exerce cette responsabilité ça veut dire
l'importance que le président de la
république que le premier ministre ont
mis dans ce post d'avoir quelqu'un de
ces niveaux politiques de ce poids
politique aurait fait mieux que vous non
mais écoutez je veux dire je suis
vraiment j'ai pas de prendre de
susceptibilité argent les gigolos j'ai
entendu qu'à marrakech et le gros sûr je
sais très bien entendu moi je les dis ce
qui m'importe c'est que l'écologie
progresse dans notre pays si c'est
ségolène royal qui le fait tant mieux et
je vais vous dire notre rôle à nous
parlementaires écologistes et de l'ailé
en faisant des analyses des propositions
et sur la question de l'écotaxe et des
investissements vous m'avez entendu très
clairement il faut absolument et ça se
le demande à ségolène royal trouvez les
800 millions d'euros que les
collectivités locales les agglomérations
les grilles communes attendent photo kl
à projets transports collectifs parce
que non mais c'est pas rien on attend
aujourd'hui pour financer des rues
assure on attend pour des projets de
tramway j'entends y compris pour nos
héros hors d'île de france et donc on a
un vrai sujet là c'est trouver ses 800
millions si c'est sous les étrangers qui
paye bon c'est pas et peut-être un peu
simpliste au départ mais c'est un sujet
intéressant c'est vrai que quand elle
dit ségolène royal il traverse la france
qui paye même pas décent chez nous même
pas donc la tei pp bon bah quand même et
comme en plus il évite les autoroutes il
ya aussi un sujet autoroutes et moi je
suis pas en revanche pour qu'on essaye
de trouver une discussion y compris un
peu viril avec les sociétés de cac
contre la privatisation je vois qui ça
rapporte et c'est pas le sujet du jour
jeudi suis pas encore la nationalisation
parce que il semble pas que ce soit la
ligne du gouvernement mais quelque part
ça doit être un argument et moi je
souhaite que les sociétés d'autoroutes
elle paye et pas celui qui prend les
autoroutes les sociétés de la drogue
comme un ton font des bénéfices un mal
encore un terrain d'entente avec
ségolène royal assure l'écotaxe
apparemment ça peut se débloquer entre
vous sur ce sujet vous pouvez trouver
une entente alors on va parler
maintenant de la situation des verts
politiquement de votre jugement sur le
parti socialiste qui change de tête ce
mardi avec jean louis prévost de la fp
qui nous rejoint d'abord voyons cette
interrogation qui parcourt certains de
vos militants favorables nouvelle
alliance non plus verts ps mais vert
rouge le reportage de jérôme bonnard fin
mars à grenoble le candidat écologiste
gagne les municipales le flux d'une
alliance encore rare avec le parti de
gauche de jean luc mélenchon mais ce
dernier rêve de reproduire cette union
aux prochaines élections le refus des
verts de faire partie du gouvernement
valls ne fait qu'attiser cette envie
certains écologistes prônent cette
nouvelle ligne cette rupture par rapport
à cette alliance un petit peu
trop trop serré avec le parti socialiste
qu'on a vécu jusqu'à présent mais c'est
du passé et pour ça il faut que en
interne la politique d'europe écologie
les verts et le courage d'être
réaffirmée d'être équilibrés vert
la gauche en quelque sorte c'est à dire
ceux qui pensent que l'austérité c'est
pas bien pour l'écologie et c'est pas
bien pour la population jacques boutault
n'aurait cependant pas été réélu maire
sans le soutien du parti socialiste
mais samedi dernier c'est du côté du
front de gauche qu'ils se rallier pour
la grande marche contre l'austérité les
drapeaux étaient plutôt rouges que verts
mais du côté du parti de gauche ont les
convaincus que les écologistes y compris
jean vincent placé céderont à la
tentation un jour ou l'autre le temps de
digérer ces deux années passées au
gouvernement
je le dis sans esprit polémique mais
quand vous avez quelques mois comme cela
quelques années au gouvernement que vous
avez dû quand même supporter une
politique n'était pas la vôtre europe et
puis il faut se désintoxiquer un peu
donc et je suis sûr que connaissant
jean-vincent à la fois ses convictions
et puis son je dirais son sens d'une
certaine stratégie je pense que lui
aussi se portera mandé le problème de
savoir comment nous devenons
majoritaires pour les idées que nous
portons et c'est une question qu'il
faudra peut-être leur poser dans
quelques mois à la tête du parti
écologiste il n'est officiellement pas
question d'alliance trop de divergences
notamment au niveau de l'europe prudence
aussi sur la transition énergétique cher
aux écologistes un peu moins pour les
communistes
au final ce sont les électeurs qui
pourrait renvoyer cette idée d'union aux
oubliettes le centre de gravité des
électeurs écologistes c'est plutôt la
droite du ps c'est pas la gauche du ps
donc il ya les distorsions entre
adhérents et électeurs donc voilà je
suis pas certain qu'il soit que
l'électeur de base soit aussi
enthousiaste pour mélenchon que le
serait certains adhérents voir
dirigeants d'europe écologie les verts
pour l'heure la priorité c'est l'europe
est un bon score des écologistes au
scrutin du 25 mai prochain pourrait
aussi remettre leur participation
gouvernementale au goût du jour
voilà jean louis prévost de la fête avec
jean-louis bonsoir michel bonsoir devant
l'assemblée
alors demain la direction du parti
communiste va rencontrer la direction
d'europe écologie les verts où il serait
peut-être est-ce que c'est les prémices
d'un premier rapprochement non ce sont
des réunions régulières c'est ce que
j'avais appris quand j'étais losc
international depuis qu'emmanuel que c
est à la tête du parti avait pas une
rencontre à ce niveau là oui oui mais
c'est notre stratégie d'ailleurs qui
s'est installée je suis à prétention
d'avoir été un peu un aspirateur de ce
que je t'appelle le multilatéralisme
dans les relations partidaire à gauche
c'est à dire le fait d'avoir des
relations avec le parti socialiste et le
parti communiste français avec le parti
radical de gauche à l'ensemble des
forces constitutives et y compris
d'ailleurs le parti de gauche moi même
d'ailleurs j'ai eu une rencontre très
amicale il ya huit jours avec jean luc
mélenchon donc on discute on discutait
du fonds brisant prix que jean luc
mélenchon on a beaucoup parlé de de
l'ukraine pour comparer des questions
internationales c'est lui qui m'a
convaincu d'être moins radicale parce
qu'elle lui dénonce des néo-fascistes
agglo non non ces termes là je ne les
prends reprend pas à mon compte
évidemment léger conteste mais c'est pas
le sujet ce que si vous lire on va
repartir notre part et d'ukraine à
richard serra mai
sur cette discussion qui est très
importante moi j'espère d'ailleurs nous
serons capables à un moment je l'avais
proposé à quelques amis de la direction
du parti que nous fassions des assises
la transformation écologique et sociale
en particulier sur la question de la
transition énergétique moi ça me ferait
très plaisir que une journée entière
mutualité parce qu'on avait fait ça là
bas à l'époque eh bien ces incapables
d'avoir l'ensemble des forces politiques
ps pc pg et les syndicats et edf et
monsieur proglio et monsieur oursel
était alors pour parler de l'énergie par
exemple ça c'est un facteur justement il
ya une pression d'une partie de vos
militants justement pour pour changer un
peu l'alliance que vous avez avec le p
socialiste et pour la remplacer avec le
front de gauche minoritaire ils existent
ils sont encouragés par votre départ du
gouvernement oui un ouais c'est ses
militants vous allez leur dire non
donc pour le moment non c'est pas pour
le moment
le curé d'une part on a des divergences
de fond heureusement qu effectivement si
on parle de l'ukraine par exemple pour
les élections européennes on voit bien
que on va pas faire une alliance avec le
parti communiste français avec ce qu'on
appelle la gauche unitaire européenne
avec le pg sur les questions européennes
on va avoir des élections régionales le
parti de gauche jean-luc mélenchon il
jacobins il est pour le supra d'une aide
de la nation française qui explique y
compris quasiment les langues régionales
c'est infâme donc manger j'enlève le
moins femme s'est s'était pas c'était
pas intéressant dans une république une
et indivisible donc voyez qu on est très
grande et pas dans les mêmes sujets
alors ce qui compte ce sont les débats
de fond est en réalité aujourd'hui à
partir du moment où nous avons y compris
incontestablement se choisit de sortir
du gouvernement la logique c'est le
rassemblement des écologistes c'est à
dire derrière nous de là ce trophée aux
européennes de parler de l'europe
parlait l'écologie de parler démocratie
et aux régionales la même manière et je
peux vous le dire là je pense que la
direction demandera aux à chacune des
régions françaises
de faire des préparer des rassemblement
des écologistes des listes autonomes
pour les jeunes alors je dis les choses
justement à grenoble eric vial a gagné
la mairie avec le parti de gauche c'est
un exemple à suivre pour vous si le
parti de gauche veut rejoindre les
listes écologistes dans ce rassemblement
autour de nos thématiques plus tôt sans
arriver avec des siennes eh bien ils
seront le bienvenu après une discussion
sur le fond mais sur les européennes
donc je vais faire ma lecture je ferme
pas la porte mais avec un objectif
important pour vous glisser européenne
vous l'avez rappelé est ce que vous
espérez arrivée devant le parti
socialiste
moi je suis être très franc si on fait
un résultat à deux chiffres je serais
très très heureux nous avons un résultat
à deux chiffres ça serait moins que lors
des dernières européennes mais la
dernière fois vous savez 2 et déjà nous
étions dans l'opposition nationale nous
étions également dans un temps où la
crise des subprimes n'avait pas tant
impacter sur l'économie mondiale en
était dans une période même de
croissance et de développement 1 juillet
2009 c'est quelque part vers le pic
d'une forme décennal de bonne heure de
bonheur d'occidental l'économie
américaine marchait bien la nôtre aussi
on arrive à une situation où il comprit
ont réussi à ré intéresser avec caisson
l'écologie taklha qu'ils arrivent fin de
copenhague où la conférence sont des
dérèglements climatiques les américains
et chinois dise circulez ya plus rien à
voir en aidant période de crise et donc
on va continuer à faire du productivisme
comme avant et les volets objectifs anti
pollution ça nous intéresse pas donc
assez partir de ce moment là déjà les
sujets colo sont plus dur à expliquer
aux citoyens qui sont dans cette crise
et après les régionales de 2010 le
grenelle environnement qui avait été
initié par jean-louis borloo et je le
salue tac et intérêts avec la fameuse
phrase de sarkozy s'est dit lassé des
colons l'environnement ça commence à
bien faire donc c'était une autre
circonstance et 2e aux circonstances on
avait daniel cohn bendit en tête de 10
c'est pas rien c'est un peu comme on
fait l'équipe b sens original ça marche
moins bien voilà on est mais depuis le
parti socialiste au pouvoir est ce que
pour vous ce serait envisageable
justement que vous soyez devant le ps
d'un côté stablement il ya
une compétition il ya des vases
communicants entre nos électorats à
cette élection européenne qui est
particulière parce que nous nous sommes
des passionnés d'europe les écologistes
incontestablement les français de son -
la participation est toujours très très
faible et c'est compliqué d'animer le
débat voilà on va le voir au mois de mai
on voit que le 25 mai je le dis à nos
téléspectateurs
après trois ponts ça va être quand même
dur d'intéresser donc c'était c'est une
élection qui
n'intéressent pas malheureusement
suffisamment donc nos candidats vont
essayer de pousser le mouvement essaie
de faire le maximum et le fait que le
parti socialiste soit en difficulté
aujourd'hui peut faire qu'effectivement
nous soyons réceptacle d'un certain
mécontentement mais je le dis très
clairement parce que je l'analyse et
cette manière là y compris un peu comme
ceux qui a dit daniel bois le
politologue de fait
la distance que nous avons prise avec le
gouvernement n'est pas forcément
susceptible de nous aider par rapport à
cet électorat ps déçu donc à yahia ce
débat là est par ailleurs je pense très
sincèrement que l'électorat extrême
gauche
gauche de la gauche ne s'ajoutent pas à
l'électorat écologiste la dynamique a
été fait à grenoble est une dynamique
d'une part formidable autour d'eric
pilote qui est quelqu'un de vraiment de
solideq charismatique déjà c'est pas
c'est une figure qu'on ne peut pas
transposer comme ça ex nihilo et la
réalité c'est que
il y avait une tradition historique à
grenoble 1-2 valeur et 40 ans d'accord
mais pour les européennes bon si c'est
si on considère qu'il ya quand même un
risque important d'effondrement du parti
socialiste également de vous
si vous pensez peut-être je ne le
parierait pas à
votre avis est-ce que ça justifierait la
formation alain remaniement ministériel
après son élection
avec votre retour le nouveau
gouvernement a été constitué il ay
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt et jeudi mais
plutôt des professionnels c'est plutôt
des gens solides moi je suis content de
l'arrivée donc de ségolène royal je suis
très content aussi je le salue mon ami
françois rebsamen qui était mon
homologue au groupe social et ça me
permet d'ailleurs de saluer l'arrivée de
didier guillaume le nouveau président du
groupe socialiste au sénat donc il ya
plutôt des gens solides et ce
gouvernement il faut qu'ils travaillent
à la vendre à revenir à faire le truc
parce que l'excusé meur dont vous nous
avez fait pendant deux ans qu'est ce que
vous faites au gouvernement
je suis très loin quand est ce que vous
vous revenez
de alors c'est pas le rythme
c'est justement est ce que ce
gouvernement va pouvoir enfin réussir en
trois ans ce qu'il n'a pas fait ce qu'on
attend de lui depuis deux ans et j'étais
en vo pour françois hollande déjà on
égalise à ça vaut beaucoup pour françois
hollande mais ce qui effectivement quand
même l'échec est patent moi je ne suis
quand même pas le plus
le plus soucieux de de rajouter des
compliments à ce qui a été fait depuis
18 mois c'est tout un chacun mais
l'échec est patent c'est plus de six
mois et sont les françaises et français
ont durement sanctionné
globalement on va mener la même
politique donc ça va quand même pas être
facile c'est aussi pour cela que cécile
duflot a souhaité sortir du gouvernement
manuel valls il met évidemment son
talent personnel dans la bataille
autorités énergique a été de
communication beaucoup en remarquable
donc est-ce que ça va avoir un effet
d'opinion malgré le fait qu'on n'ait pas
bougé de politique on va voir est-ce
qu'il est noir mon objectif avec thé
ecologist de pour les six prochains mois
à la prochaine année s'est desserré
justement d'essayer d'en mettre plus de
volontarisme économique et social et de
faire en sorte que la transition
énergétique arriver peut-être on en
parlera de faire en sorte pour fasse
enfin cette réforme territoriale qui va
plus
tard mais manuel vals justement vous en
parler alors à votre avis est-ce que
c'est la tour de la gauche pour 2010 est
face à un françois hollande ça c'est le
voyait comme un joker prétendants mais
on a jaugé pas de la politique après
l'échec patent je suis pas la politique
fiction et vous ne voudrez pas de dire
ça c'est ça qui me différencie de vous
vous êtes d'ailleurs de bons analyses
parfois même de deux bons
pronostiqueurs moi je suis pas dans
l'analyse et je ne suis pas seulement la
projection moi je suis un acteur de la
vie ma décision en accord parlementaire
qui a vocation à aider le gouvernement
et si vous me posez la question un peu
plus factuelle de savoir quelle est
notre position rapport au gouvernement
je t'ai dit on ne participant plus mais
nous soutenons bien sûr alors maintenant
arrêtez
soutien sans participation mais je le
dis très clairement avec des
propositions à cracher sur les textes
regardez sur la loi dernière agricole et
bien s'entourer vêler nous allons la
voter ce soir nous ne sommes pas
satisfaits tout mais nous pensons grâce
à l'action de joël labbé de marie
christine blandin nous pensons que nous
avons eu des avancées dans la discussion
par rapport à l'agroécologie et donc
qu'on fait on fait on va les cils du
flat quitter le gouvernement alors est
ce que vous considérez que maintenant
elle a le champ libre pour une
candidature vraiment offensive en 2017
mais alors là je vais vous dire
celles et ceux y compris d'ailleurs le
président la république qui ne penserait
qu'à 2017 ce serait le plus sûr moyen du
vainqueur de rater le coup pour
l'intéressé ait eu ou et est aussi ça
n'a pas de sens le rapport à la
situation du pays enfin moi franchement
concentrons nous sur le travail en jeu
c'est déjà assez lourd françois hollande
on assiste à un tournant du quinquennat
avec la fin du président normal ont dit
qu'ils le françois hollande centralisée
des six nations c'est de plus en plus
aux nominations est ce que ça vous
inquiète non mais je vous dirais je
crois malheureusement que c'est la
logique vème république c'est que même
quelqu'un de plutôt
démocrates attachés à la vie
parlementaire et très ouverts comme
françois hollande à la fin il est dans
la logique de l'institution et qu'est ce
que je peux lui reprocher à peine parce
que la réalité c'est qu'il faut changer
l'institution là c'est comme ça pendant
trois ans je penserai je pense que là il
ya effectivement il a mis beaucoup
d'autorité il a remanié à l'elysée il a
remanié au gouvernement il a remanié au
parti socialiste votre avis alors sur
jean christophe cambadélis parce que
vous avez salué le réverbère fessionnels
au gouvernement s'est félicité de celui
qui de l'arrivée de celui qui fut un
artisan de la gauche plurielle on s'en
souvient avec les mêmes gestes pas moi
je vais vous dire je suis connu pour ça
j'aime bien les gens qui sont
professionnels et là dont toutes les
strates on voit que un cavalière ainsi
la renforcer avec jean christophe
cambadélis c'est d'une part un stratège
est quelqu'un qui conceptualise les
questions du gauche française de façon
très intéressante il a fêté en papier de
blogs sur la question aujourd'hui de
l'extrême droite de la droite de
l'ensemble de dégoût genre avec lui si
quelqu'un de très intelligent c'est
quelqu'un de très intelligent de très
structuré et d'organiser et je vais vous
dire dans la période ça peut pas faire
de mal donc moi j'ai pas mêler des
affaires du parti socialiste met
d'accord on aura on aura beaucoup de
travail à faire avec jean christophe
cambadélis et on le fera ensemble est-ce
que vous pensez que françois hollande
pour éviter la dissolution jusqu'à la
fin de son quinquennat c'est aussi un
peu un petit fiction mais on a quand
même intérêt à voir des résultats dans
les quinze mois qui viennent parce que
la mer la pression
je la voir c'est la défiance vis-à-vis
du politique est très donc la tension
met en garde m la défiance est très
forte abstention c'est bien sûr le front
national et puis une violence une
violence des citoyens et aussi au delà
de la violence et de la colère à la
limite peut-être plus facile à
appréhender dans le dialogue il ya la
réalité aussi
d'un lieu d'un sentiment d'inutilité
d'épaulé d'impuissance d'applications me
sidère c'est pour ça que je pense qu'à
un moment il faut quand même remettre
oui je vais vous dire des choses de la
puissance dans d'acteurs politiques donc
voilà vous êtes satisfait sur ce plan là
françois hollande a reçu des économistes
qui sont favorables à un smic un peu
réduit au rabais
c'est ce que dit également aujourd'hui
le patron des patrons monsieur gattaz
une espèce de smic inférieur donc la
norme pour embaucher des jeunes comment
est-ce que vous réagissez vous
si on veut la dissolution où il faut
faire ça brille c'est sûr non mais c'est
pas sérieux il ya une demande évidente
de sécurité pas de sécurité seulement
d'ailleurs des biens des personnes et de
sécurité dans bonjour sans suite et de
sécurité dans la santé et il ya des
besoins aussi de rassurer les françaises
et français quant au pouvoir d'achat sur
internet un terme qui plaît pas
tellement écolo parce que bon voilà ça
fait croissance consumérisme mais la
réalité du pouvoir d'achat des mieux les
plus défavorisés quand même c'est un
vrai sujet mais où donc c'est absurde
voilà je vais vous le dire c'est absurde
c'est ça ça fera trois fois plus
d'argent de dangereux trois fois plus de
manifestations que pour le cpe qui a
fait chuter villepin et voilà donc mais
manuel valls est quelqu'un de très
intelligent donc il évitera tomber dans
dans ces impasses l'accord et m'emmène
en réalité et je le fais un petit couple
est quand même sur un sujet qui
m'intéresse vraiment une revanche à ce
que la question compétitivité coût du
travail
ça ne marche pas on va pas faire pour
moins trois mois cinq pour ça on va pas
être conquérir des marchés ce n'est pas
vrai dans un monde aujourd'hui ou au
brésil selon le salarié c'est 400 euros
en chine c'est 250 au maroc etc ça n'a
aucun sens ça ne marche pas il faut donc
avoir des produits à valeur ajoutée
c'est pour ça qu'on est bon sur la
gastronomie c'est pour ça qu'on est bon
sur le luxe même sur l'aéronautique
voyez vous dire c'est l'écologie ce qui
le dit on est bon sur l'aéronautique
parce qu'on est des plus values donc il
faut faire quelque chose au delà de la
plus value et on peut même vendre y
compris cher parfois mais le truc que la
compétitivité coût du travail voilà
c'est c'est une impasse aussi cependant
ça fait deux ans que je dis ça et je le
répète malheureusement dans le vide mais
on me rendre à
justifie jean-louis alors à ce titre
nous arrive maintenant et l'on va parler
d'un sujet sur lequel donc vous avez été
précurseur jean vincent placé la fin des
départements manuel valls l'annoncent et
oui et vous vous l'a réclamée de longue
date et vous voilà isolé tous les deux
sophie normands
après le non cumul des mandats manuel
valls ouvre un nouveau bras de fer au
sénat et annonce mercredi dernier la
suppression des départements d'ici à
2021 droite gauche confondues les
sénateurs se sont aussitôt
majoritairement élevé contre la
brutalité selon un de l'annonce et
faut-il faire disparaître les
départements moi je suis plutôt un jeune
alice mais j'hésite sur le fait d'aller
si vite alors qu' on n'a rien inventé
pour faire de la proximité de nos noms
un peu de temps pour mettre en place un
dispositif qui à gré tout le monde pour
une bonne partie des sénateurs le
département demeure un échelon essentiel
la ou les régions apparaissent parfois
trop éloignés des territoires ruraux
autres anicroche dans une assemblée
sénatoriale qui compte 10 % de président
de conseil général les élus se sentent
dépossédés de leurs prérogatives
les sénateurs sont élus au sein des
départements une première échelons donc
peut-être que l'on peut imaginer qu'à
moyen terme c'est le sénat qui est visé
à travers la suppression des
départements c'est notre circonscription
électorale d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas
de secteurs comme les députés et là
dessus je crois que c'est très sensible
un seul groupe à apporter d'office son
soutien au projet le groupe écologiste
emmenée par jean vincent placé où je
pense qu'il n'a pas réfléchi je pense
qu'ils ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
département je pense que il n'a même
jamais siéger dans un conseil général et
que par conséquent on peut pas raisonner
comme ça de façon je dirais abrupte à
l'emporte-pièce les écologistes se
disent talent anvers en phase avec leur
temps quand d'autres selon eux reste
avec une représentation de
l'organisation territoriale française
héritée de la révolution
seul contre tous nul doute en tout cas
que les écologistes seront les meilleurs
alliés du premier ministre au palais du
luxembourg
eux qui réclament la suppression des
départements de longue date
questions à jean vincent placé de toute
nature de toutes natures ou foulard et
oui j'ai une partie personnel vous savez
dans le on y vient pas d'en parler on va
parler la réforme territoriale on l'a vu
dans le sujet des élus dénoncent le
caractère brutal des annonces de manuel
valls est ce qu'à un mètre d'un problème
de méthode sur ce dossier car nous
arrêtons ça fait on en est mais je sais
pas moi je ça fait vingt ans chez la vie
politique j'ai vu passer mais des stocks
de rapport est d'ailleurs tout à fait
honorable et respectueux avec
respectable sous ces rapports il ya eu
le rapport raffarin moi j'avais déjà
salué sa reprend en gros ce qu'a dit
free les lycées mais les élus les élus à
un moment ils veulent sauter en touche à
rien voilà c'est ça la réalité moi je
suis ici j'ai essayé mais respect pour
mes collègues sénateurs le président
bayle avait fait un gros travail sur les
états généraux donc on fait des états
généraux ont fait des rapports il y
avait eu raffarin je me souviens d'un
rapport warsmann de mémoire
mais moi je j'apprends à ne plus à ne
pas défaire de critiques inutiles ça
fait pas avancer le débat la chose qui
est clair c'est que depuis 1791 il ya
des départements et à l'époque on avait
fait département taillé pour que l'on
puisse aller d'un point à un autre dans
une journée du cheval vous voyez à peu
près la vision stratégique en termes de
territoire
ensuite on avait fait des régions je me
souviens parce que voilà acheter un prêt
des sciences politiques qu'on avait fait
deux normandies parce qu'à l'époque
valéry giscard d'estaing avait deux
fidèles l'un à rouen et s'appelait jean
luc lanouilh applique mois qui viennent
ça mais bon
michèle et michel d'ornano à caen
donc il fallait faire 2 dans mon dit
donc vous voyez à peu près comment les
choses ont été faites et on a fait à la
française c'est à dire les départements
les 36000 communes les 26 régions on
s'est dit on va rajouter des agglos
basse que comme on peut pas supprimer
les communes on va
aller en plus et ça personne n'en parle
on a les fameux syndicats intercommunaux
de l'eau des déchets de l'accessit et
des ordures de saab en voilà bon ça me
plaît beaucoup voyez ce que c'est l'avis
de l'élu à la fin aussi agent 5 est ce
que vous y croyez à cette réforme
du gouvernement est gelé lui dit on a
voté contre c'est on à cette situation
la banque évidemment à faire des
métropoles en plus là mais on est quand
même moment et je suis très heureux moi
parce que ce que je dis depuis au sénat
depuis deux ans je dis depuis deux cent
le manuel valls l'a dit pas un mot pour
mot mais dans sa philosophie dans son
discours de politique générale donc pour
les écolos niche on est content on est
content après yann tige
quand j'entends les collègues qui siège
dans fan depuis 30 ans dans sénateur et
président français généraux et qui dit
ça on n'a pas été assez concertée non
mais jeudi on est là on est on est chez
les fous pour reprendre une expression
populaire font un moment c'est pas
possible en effet un moment il faut
écouter les françaises et français les
français et françaises en ont marre sur
les questions de l'emploi voilà ça c'est
clair j'ai la prétention de penser
qu'ils sont assez attentifs bien plus
que nos élites avec et son écologie
notamment dans la vie quotidienne moi je
vois le débat pollution 1 et
ils ont
l'efficacité ils veulent de l'efficacité
ils veulent que le gouvernement soit
efficace ils veulent qu administrations
centrales se simplifient sassano débat
moi je te j'ai toujours dit au président
et pdg dit l'actrice en administration
centrale et est essentielle il faut plus
de gens dans les territoires
particulièrement en difficulté les
territoires ruraux les banlieues est pas
tout le monde concentré je suis désolé
de faire un peu le projet 10 mai dans le
7e arrondissement voilà il faut que les
gens sortent c'est pareil pour la police
et leurs normes et moi je suis
rapporteur général rapporteur spécial du
budget sur la police et gendarmerie on
s'éteint un mal conduit à chaque fois il
ya énormément de gens dans les guérites
etc et pas assez dans les quartiers est
et là c'est la même histoire des
collectivités territoriales les
françaises et les français ok c'est vrai
que quand c'est chez eux ils ont un fils
nîmes beast mais il faut
référence d'ailleurs il l'aura un
curseur de niveau 2 d'autorité et de
volonté réformatrice sur ce sujet parce
qu'on comptait sur vous oui mais ce que
cette volonté de réforme en tout cas est
ce que ça montre que le gouvernement
finalement a fait une croix sur le
maintien à gauche du sénat en septembre
prochain nous pas de raison mais
d'évidence les élections municipales et
ont été perdus ça va être plus difficile
que prévu mais ce n'est pas perdu pour
le sénat c'est le temps mais il faut
faire les élections moi je vais vous
dire je n'ai pas peur je pensais pas un
seul instant en 2011 que nous gagnerions
non donc je pensais pas que nous
gagnerions et j'ai eu tort donc voici
quatorze vous allez perdre
sur manuel valls à j'avais envie de vous
poser une question un peu plus personnel
sur son discours de politique générale
il a beaucoup évoqué notamment la fin
son parcours fils d'émigrés est ce que
cette partie là de son discours vous a
ému vous a particulièrement touché sur
lui barcelone et moi je suit séoul si
j'ose dire et il a été naturalisé
beaucoup plus tard que moi d'ailleurs je
crois à 18 ou 20 ans et pour nous c'est
la passion de la france c'est c'est la
pression de la france de la république
de cette vingtaine celle qui donne cette
chance de parler français déjà moi je ne
parlais pas français quand je suis
arrivé à à sept ans et demi je suis un
peu comme ce que j'ai dit j'ai toujours
dit que j'étais petit sept ans et demi
et c'est moi j'ai on aime cette
france-là celle qui justement faisait
l'effort d'intégrer d'apprendre les
valeurs la citoyenneté voilà c'est
important est ce que vous vous verriez
vous aussi comme le premier ministre il
a beaucoup d'avancé sur moi on verra
mais c'est pas le temps ça se rattrape
s'était pas non plus attention je me
savais oui on en parlera avec des
comprimés non non il et puis en plus
vous le savez ma vie et que je suis
d'une grande sérénité pour plein de
raisons voilà voilà pour plein de
raisons comme je le parle d'accès du
cese est vrai qu elle l affaire des pv
un impayé de la région ile-de-france
alors ce week-end sonaca canal+ vous
avez été accusé par la vice-présidente
de la région michèle sabban de ne pas
avoir tout réglé aujourd'hui jean paul
huchon le président de la région
ile-de-france a pris votre défense qu'il
assure que tout est réglé auprès de la
région alors finalement qui a raison est
ce que monsieur le savons est une
menteuse écoutez moi je vais vous dire
les choses sont simples d'ailleurs je me
suis rendu compte qu'il est de quelque
chose parce que je suis pas du tout dans
beaucoup conduire cette polémique me
navre et y compris certains des amis
m'ont dit mehdi le parce que ce sont des
pv de stationnement voilà y'a pas je
pratique ces nuits thèse pas de je ne
sais quoi ce sont des pv de
stationnement droit non mais je le dis
parce que j'ai compris qu'il y avait des
délires qui partait sur les réseaux
sociaux xterra ce sont des pv de
stationnement c'est pas mal hein c'est
une période je te le dis très
tranquillement il ya pas grand monde qui
paient les pv dans les collectivités
territoriales parce que il y avait des
mauvaises habitudes qu'elle avait laissé
une grosse ardoise oui je les dis je
dise n'excuse pas d'ailleurs je décris
les faits ce sont des pv de sa seule
branche paiements en bas de chez moi
trop souvent et c'était avant 2009 voilà
donc y'a quand même cinq ans et je ne
vous a pas échappé que je suis le seul
auquel on s'est intéressé dans cette
histoire c'est les autres manifestement
ça intéresse personne un petit travail
dans quel peut-être impossible
non non mais voilà les noms les noms
mais moi je
suis ambitieux j'ai un petit côté
investigations les réseaux sociaux
donc là les faits sont simples voilà ce
sont les faits on quand les seuls à
chaque fois qu'on m'a demandé de régler
j'ai réglé rubis sur l'ongle on peut
critiquer mais
récemment a dit des choses à la
télévision je vais vous dire aussi et
vous le savez l'émission pré enregistrés
par la boîte de production de
monsieur lebon qui aimait chez incrimine
pas déjà incriminé ni journalistes ni
les journalistes ni ni canal+ canal+
voilà j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour
y compris l'esprit canal où j'ai pas de
preuves de sujets de polémique de la
corporation si j'ose dire ni avec canal
là sur le sujet de cette émission si je
suis désolé de vous le dire c'était pas
du journalisme si ce n'est même pas
c'est même pas de journaliste politique
c'est pas du journaliste vraiment passé
passé des
enregistrements hors plateau c'est comme
si vous passiez ce qu'on s'est dit oui
oppose après parce que le micro et là
c'est tout de même incroyable jeudi
c'est une première en france c'était une
première
et donc avec ces éléments là je suis
désolé il faut quand même des gens
comprennent et bien j'ai décidé avec mon
conseil mon avocat maître emmanuel
pierrât de porter plainte pour
diffamation
et vous verrez que je ne mendie pas plus
alors pourquoi parce que la procédure
est ainsi donc en pente pour x et
ensuite un juge d'instruction qui sera
saisie il fera son travail et je vais
vous dire c'est la première fois dieu
sait que j'ai lu et entendu des
mensonges totalement avérée dans
certains journaux du mercredi matin dans
les pages de dans certains échos et y
compris je le dis cette boîte de
production qui fait le
cette émission je suis pas comment la
qualifier du supplément sur canal et qui
est la même qui fait le petit journal je
peux vous dire que ça décrédibilise
totalement l'ensemble de votre
profession je suis désolé de vous le
dire très bien voilà une dernière fois
vous étiez très cher une erreur de
janvier vous vous étiez saluons en
personne ne vous croit d'ailleurs pas ce
que c'est ils sont sept antennes laissez
le sécher ni les choses c'est un chéneau
bord merci maintenant on a compris que
tout était peiné on à l'attestation
officiel de l'administration merci un
peu touché par cette affaire
le temps de s'épancher sur place et
merci prochain preuve par trois ce sera
dans quinze jours maintenant notre
invité sera laurent wauquiez bonsoir est
très vite